you know what I really am selfish
oh yeah it is
we can't believe it's been three years
since we last saw you Damon he started
out as a really creepy mean vampire but
then we got to see your caring side we
are so glad that you and Elena got your
happily ever after but we still have a
lot of questions about what went on in
Mystic Falls some things really don't
make sense and we'd like you to explain
vampire diaries ended almost three years
ago but there are still a lot of
unanswered questions there were a lot of
complicated storylines and some just
fell flat keep watching to find out the
10 biggest plot holes but everyone
missed in Vampire Diaries and to
function
I need human blood don't ever call me a
vampire Bonnie's magic Bonnie Bennett as
a super important character in Vampire
Diaries in fact by the end of the series
she might be the most important
character when we first meet Bonnie
she's just Elena's best friend but soon
we learned that she is a witch and not
just any witch bonnie is an extremely
powerful witch from a long line of
magical women by the last season
Bonnie's powers are so strong she's
practically a deity but the show was
only aired for eight seasons in the
beginning she was just learning how to
use her powers she first had to discover
she was a witch and then her grandmother
had to teach her then her magic just
gets stronger and stronger but she has
an amazing control of it it seems so
unrealistic that she would learn how to
control her magic so quickly maybe she's
spending all of her spare time
practicing that doesn't make sense
either it seems like having that much
magic would take a long time to master
it was often convenient for the plot so
the show's creators just overlooked this
Stefan's choice Stefan Salvatore is a
vampire and he proves over and over that
he is a really strong powerful vampire
he has super strength and he's pretty
old which makes him even more powerful
he has super speed extreme agility and
can heal very quickly like all the other
vampires another vampire ability is
endurance and Safin can endure way more
than a human can
so vampires are pretty special twice
diff'ent has to choose to save Elena or
someone else in the show the second time
he has to choose between Elena or Matt
when their car is underwater but why it
shouldn't have taken Stefan much effort
at all to save the humans with all the
powers he has he should have been able
to save both of them but having to
choose between two people made the
scenes all the more intense and it
helped advance their storylines by
dramatic effect isn't a good enough
reason to totally disregard Stefan's
powers we wish the show had addressed
this in more detail the white oak tree
do you remember the whole white oak tree
storyline it was really important in
season 3 the great white oak tree is
extremely magical because it's one of
nature's eternal objects Esther used the
magic of the tree in her spell to make
the family in mortal it's tied to the
magic of the originals the wood of the
oak tree is the only thing that can stop
an original but the show also says that
if it ceases to exist
the originals will - that's a great
premise but the show doesn't follow
through the originals burned down the
first tree 300 years before and nothing
happened then there was a new tree that
was cut down for Wickery bridge why
didn't this end the originals supposedly
if the white oak tree was burned all
hope was lost but it did burn and
nothing happened why did they make such
a big deal about this tree and burning
it only not to finish the storyline this
pothole drives us crazy the cures
requirements the writers of the Vampire
Diaries loved introducing magical
objects to the show the white oak tree
is just one of these the cure is another
but like the oak trees some of the cure
just didn't add it up the cure is a cure
for vampirism and immortality it will
alter an immortal human so that they can
age and pass away the cure
he said there was a cure there are
different versions of the cure because
of some alternate dimensions but the
version that is most important in the
show is an elixir this elixir can begin
jested and it mixes with the blood Silas
makes a big deal about needing to drain
the person whose blood possesses the
cure but when Elena gave chiffon the
cure only a needle fool was needed with
Silas mine or is this an inconsistency
it's also not clear how they immortal it
needs to take the cure the rules seem to
change a lot sometimes they need to
drink and other times it needs to be
injected into their bloodstream we have
no idea what the real answer is vervain
supply another magical object that has
inconsistencies in the show is vervain
vervain is a powerful herb that has anti
vampire properties it's a lot like
garlic another vampire lore vervain can
help a human avoid vampire compulsion
that's when the vampires glamour you to
do things you don't want to do all the
human has to do is ingest the herb or
hold it if a vampire eats vervain they
get really sick here's an interesting
fact the very vein is actually a real
herb but throughout the show vervain
supply is inconsistent sometimes it's
really hard to find in certain episodes
they have to track down a vervain dealer
to obtain it then other times it's
really easy to find it's everywhere it
seems to totally depend on the storyline
we understand supply and demand but the
inconsistency is just too great the show
tries to explain the fluctuating supply
like when Pastor Jung blows up the farm
but it's just an herb and it isn't
illegal so it really shouldn't be that
hard to locate it's one other plot point
that the writers change when it's
convenient
do you love shows like vampire diaries
if so you'll love the things click the
subscribe button for more plot holes
theories and cool TV news if you're
watching on your phone make sure you
turn on your YouTube notifications in
your settings then you'll never miss
another awesome video Logan's house one
of the most common pieces of vampire
lore is the invitation rule vampires
cannot enter a human home unless the
human invites them in they literally
can't even stick a toe over the
threshold of the door Vampire Diaries is
no different the invitation rule seems
to be a hard and fast rule if a Hugh
and owns the home the vampires can't
enter without an invite but then there's
Logan fell remember Logan he was a
reporter for WP kw9 in Mystic Falls
he was Jenna's ex-boyfriend you know the
one who cheated on her
Logan tries to harm Damon but Damon wins
the fight Anna makes Logan drink her
blood so he comes back as a vampire I
can't get into my house because my foot
won't go through the door
Logan then tries to go home but he can't
enter his own house it's a funny story
line that causes some issues but it
honestly makes no sense
Logan lives alone it's his house he
should be able to enter it even though
he's a vampire
maybe someone else's name is on the deed
to the house he might have just been
renting it so he's not the owner but
it's never explained it all if you think
that's a major plot hole keep watching
to find out problems with other vampire
roles they're real originals the
original vampires are a pretty major
part of the vampire diaries rose reveals
their existence to Elena Stefan and
Damon early on the Mikaelson family are
the originals
they are the first vampires instead of
being turned they were created by magic
by the witch Esther
Michael had lost the son and wanted the
rest of his family to become immortal
they are supposed to be the oldest
immortals they're the original vampires
which makes them stronger than all the
others for them there's Silas he was the
first immortal to he was even older than
the originals but the show originally
said that the originals were the first
immortals it makes sense that they are
the very first vampires
Silas isn't a vampire he doesn't even
want to be associated with them but the
show totally backtracked on the
originals when they introduced Silas
it's a huge glaring inconsistency that
bugs a lot of fans is they had just said
the originals were the first vampires it
wouldn't be a problem
Katherine's death Katherine Pierce was
born Katerina Petrova in the Middle Ages
she was born a doppelganger which means
she was supposed to perish in the place
of the immortal she looks like she was
one of Amara's doppelgangers Katherine
turns herself into a vampire to avoid
being sacrificed by the originals
please I'm Katherine Paris I'm a
survivor when Katherine finally passes
away bonnie has become the anchor on the
other side
every supernatural that meets their fate
has to pass through her she can feel
every supernatural passing but for some
reason when Catherine kicks the bucket
bonnie has no idea it's a huge deal that
bonnie is the anchor so why doesn't she
feel Katherine's presence it was
convenient for the plot that Bonnie
didn't know but it made absolutely no
sense with how the show is set Bonnie up
as the anchor this is such a major
inconsistency that totally messes up how
we view Bonnie we aren't quite sure why
the show made such a big mistake the
sunlight rule like most vampires The
Vampire Diaries characters can't go into
the sunlight without protection but in
the show there is a way around this
witches have an enchanted piece of
jewelry with a lapis lazuli stone when
the vampires wear them they are
protected from the sun's effects it's
pretty convenient but like the other
magical objects in Vampire Diaries
there's an inconsistency when Stefan or
Damon are in the Sun without their
daylight ring it's not a huge deal they
don't burn super quickly at all it's the
same thing when Elena becomes a vampire
but when other vampires like Isabel
forget their daylight ring it's terrible
they burn up really quickly we know the
show didn't want to off their main
characters in such a boring way but this
plot hole is pretty major there
shouldn't be a difference in how the
vampires are affected by the Sun vampire
strength there's one other vampire fool
that has some major inconsistencies in
vampire diaries that's the rule about
vampire strength in the show the rule is
that the older the vampire the stronger
they are I'm older than you and stronger
don't get on my bad side that makes a
lot of sense all vampires have
super-strength but they get stronger as
they get older that also makes it hard
for the lead characters to win a fight
against older vampires so the show put
in an exception younger vampires with
the really strong emotions can beat an
older vampire in strength this is
convenient er the plot but it actually
makes no sense no one goes into a fight
without strong emotions how do they
determine who has the strongest feelings
we think that a desire to live is a very
strong emotion why isn't that enough for
the older vampires it seems like the
show didn't think this one all the way
through and that's it for the 10 biggest
plot holes which Vampire Diaries plot
hole bothered you the most
be shy let us know in the comments
section below thanks for watching give
this video a big thumbs up if you love
the Vampire Diaries
we'll see you next time on the things